you
hi everyone it's Jerry Aman chess calms
tactics train I'm gonna try it three
more puzzles this first one it's white
to move and I'm just going to share my
thoughts along the way so let's see
where we stand with this one materialize
just doing a quick check we're balanced
with the material and what next hmm okay
what should I have referenced first this
Bishop is unprotected so I think there
might be something we can do with that
there might also be something with the
move g4 since that's a fork I think I'm
on to something I really do think I'm on
to something here with this bishop being
unprotected and this being a fork
possibility there is also this capture
and I think there's a timing issue with
this one when exactly to capture on EA
we could capture on d6 let me just point
this out if Bishop takes Bishop on the
first move Knight takes and if Luke
takes rook then there's the knight that
can recapture and there would be one
less unprotected piece for example if
Bishop takes Bishop Knight takes rook
take struck Queen recaptures now there's
an unprotected Knight on d6 and a bishop
that's unprotected on h5 so I'm thinking
that by playing g4 first after Bishop
takes pawn now we take on EA Queen
recaptures take on d6 the knight
recaptures and now with the knight being
uh protected on d6 and the bishop being
unprotected on g4 there's this quiet
move Queen to F
or attacking the knight and the bishop
and I don't believe there's a way that
black can move so that both pieces will
be defended hmm these are always very
tricky whenever there's a quiet movement
involved so let me double check this one
that is my first thought though g4g for
you pretty much have to take right g4 if
Bishop takes Queen takes and now the
Queen is defending the pond and there's
still this fork present there's also no
vulnerabilities really with the white
pieces the rook is protected on c1 with
this variation g4 Bishop takes rook
takes rook Queen takes Bishop takes
Bishop Knight takes the bishops
protected the rook on C once protected
the knight on v3 is protected which
means that there's maybe no counter
tactic that black can use to exploit
White's position since there's not any
pieces that are unprotected I think I'm
gonna go with that
g4 first or no no no no no no no I think
um I have to play rook takes rook first
that's the first one rook takes rook
first if g4 then then there's rook takes
rook first rook takes rook and then
after Bishop takes g4 Bishop takes here
the knight gets to recapture and the
queen is there to defend e6 so I think
this has to come first let me give this
one quick thought one more try here rook
takes rook Queen takes it's an only move
g4 Bishop takes Bishop takes Bishop
Knight takes bishop unprotected Knight
on d6 unprotected Bishop on g4 Queen to
f4 hits ball tonight in Bishop and I'm
not seeing a way that the Queen can move
too
defend both but actually there is isn't
there the Queen can moved to d7
defending the knight and the bishop on
g4 but you know what then there's then
there's Knights e5 hmm I think this is
the only square the Queen could go to
that would defend g4 and d6 if she's
kicked off of this square she can defend
one of these two squares but not both so
this is maybe even one step deeper this
puzzle rook takes Queen takes g4 Bishop
takes pawn Bishop takes Bishop Knight
takes bishop Queen f4 Queen d7 defends
g4 and d6 but then comes Knight c5 okay
that I think that's finally it now I
actually with Knight c5 this rook is
this rook on c1 would be unprotected but
I don't see a way that the Queen can
move from d7 and attack this unprotected
piece okay this is getting far too
complicated let me start off with this
hopefully it's right it is
and now g4 that is correct okay now
Bishop takes that's right and now Queen
f4 that's right Queen d7 Knight c5 is
what I thought is it's the end of the
puzzle it is I actually feel very good
about this one
it took forever but um I just gave
myself a pat on the back for that one I
guess
all right I've focused on this one
enough let's just dive into puzzle two
of three okay once again white to move
hmm all right checking moves there's a
knight check and that's it if it's
blacks turn to move there are some
checking moves Queen here probably not
Knight here probably not Queen
takes here probably not so not really
any not really any great checking moves
so I think this allows white to make
some quiet move to start let's see queen
h6 is my first thought threatening mate
1 hmm how are you gonna stop that
alright the Queen there the King would
have the King has no legal moves once
the Queen plays to h6 what are you doing
about Queen age ain't Queen h6 there is
rook takes pawn and then if Queen h8
there's King takes Knight so Queen h6
move I think could be met with rook
takes pawn and then all of a sudden the
night is not defended so Queen H a check
King takes Knight is available notice
Queen h6 rook takes pawn rook takes rook
now this rook is unprotected and is no
longer sheltering the King on this
diagonal from check Smith so this allows
Queen d5 check picking up the rook hmm
let's still run with this though there
might be some tactic against the Queen
Queen h6
rook takes pawn queen h6 rook takes pawn
I believe would be the only try Queen h6
night check you take you're defending
the knight with the rook and pawn so
that's probably not a good idea so Queen
h6 rook takes pawn seems like the only
response and do we have time
something other than a rook takes rook
Queen h6 rook takes pawn queen check
King takes Knight and the follow-up is
I'm not seeing it you give a check on h7
but the knight could block maybe then
there's a rook check i something seems
like it's off with that one I don't know
let's see what about Queen getting on
this diagonal to try to get to h8
there's more than one direction you can
move the Queen to try and get to AJ but
moving it on this dog and I'll let's say
to be to Knight g7 and I'm not sure what
you do at that point
hmm Knight h6 check King h7 where do we
go from there I have no idea it just
feels so right to do this move let's
look at it one more time almost four
minutes on this one Queen h6 rook takes
pawn and what next Queen h6 rook takes
pawn not seeing it let's see Queen h6
rook takes pawn and I really don't know
what the follow-up would be Queen h6
rook takes pawn rook takes rook Queen d5
check and then king h2 Queen takes rook
I don't know what the follow-up would be
after that Wow Oh what about this is
this a move
I'm going in a completely different
direction now I'm ready to throw in the
towel of this one
if Queen to d7 it's completely different
than Queen h6 Queen d7 isn't like Queen
here defending everything you're
throwing a check but just king somewhere
so many different choices I'm stumped on
this one
what's unprotected he's unprotected it's
a way to really take advantage of that
there any tricky force I hope what about
now I was just gonna say Knight check if
the King h7 Queen d7 but there's always
some piece that can get to e7 here yeah
it's not really happening with this one
is it all right I spent enough time let
me just try something I'm gonna still go
with this even though I'm pretty sure
it's wrong oh my goodness it's right
why isn't Queen d5 being played ah
really
I thought rook takes pawn would have
been good all right so seems a lot
simpler now because you could play rook
here and interfere with the Queen
defending h8 that's the intention behind
Queen c3 Queen c3 defends h8 but after
rook to e5 that blocks this that's got
to be a right there's this but it allows
Knight or queen block okay I think
looked to e5 now Knight check the queen
is watching over f4 let's just do this
and okay this is gonna be the end of the
puzzle but I'm not I'm not really a big
fan of this one I need to go to the
analysis board on this one and see what
the big idea was here let's see if I
could get this let's see how well I'm
doing here should be sort of close there
all right good enough let me just scroll
down for a second
came there Queen h6 was right by its
it's one of these you really can't can't
feel good about getting a puzzle like
this because you didn't really see it
all the way through it's not really
giving um rook takes pawn as a
possibility in the analysis or maybe I'm
just completely blind to it now here we
go this rook to e1 takes c6 right here
and then it's saying Knight to g5 Oh
Knight g5 oh let's see so they're
talking about this if rook takes pawn
not rook takes rook because of this
picking up the rook but Knight here oh
that's a sneaky move that was hard to
spot hitting the rook twice and if hook
takes rook now there's a main one -
that's the key idea that I missed this
Knight g5 move tricky ok let's close out
of this and try that last one ok puzzle
3 of 3 I'll give myself maybe half
credit for this or that puzzle all right
puzzle 3 of 3 I feel like I've seen this
one before we play as black and okay
this guy's going in this direction
alright feels like what feels like what
what are we playing for here is black um
we're not playing for a win are we ah
yes we are yes we're definitely playing
for one we could take this pawn with
check and then oh we're gonna win this
this is how this um these puzzle this
puzzle set of three is going to end
we take the pun and then win the Queen
next play and then push the pun and
that's it push our own pond you can't be
caught alright so that was simple enough
right Queen takes pawn check the King
has two legal moves if he goes here we
give a check on the diagonal win the
Queen and the pawn runs for the hills
and Queen takes pawn King here Queen
check and then we pick up the Queen
there aren't any tricky stalemate ideas
that white would have after we take the
Queen are there Queen takes pawn King
here Queen check the King can't move to
a square where once we capture the Queen
the King would be in stalemate and
similarly if the Queen if the King plays
here after we take the pawn Queen check
the King can't move to a square where
once we take the Queen it would be
stalemate so I think if this one's
pretty clear-cut no it's not what'd I
miss
are you kidding me what's wrong with my
idea of just picking up the pawn and
then uh oh my goodness do you see the
terrible blunder I made ah you goof oh
my goodness
oh man after the King moves we're in
check oh man like I wonder I want to try
this one still now that I see that mmm
could I still try it I want to get this
one ah man
I mean we could always get a stalemate
you give a check go here and the King
keeps going back and forth in the corner
and it'll it'll be a stalemate you can't
you can't tell white wouldn't be able to
win that's for sure but what's what's
the big plan here what about oh maybe
you have to insert this check first
Queen check King here and only then take
the pawn with
check with then Queen here to follow or
queen here to follow to win the Queen ah
alright I think this is this is the
first move Queen check first oh my
goodness the Queen blocks now once you
take the pawn the King moves and you're
not in check and now Queen here if King
here Queen to see seven man I feel
foolish and now this pawn simply can't
be caught details that was a big blunder
to not see that after the King moved I
would be in check I can't even give
myself half credit for that one alright
maybe I'm not the only one who fell for
it feel free to share how you did with
these three and I hope you got something
out of this video take care bye
you